This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是I-Heart播客节目。内容绝对真人真实。大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人的经历，进行那些在别处谈论着实并不安全的坦诚对话，而你在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就非得这么做，听从内心的声音去学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用硬核的方式，在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一大群人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当旁边还有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO.%，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。收听闺蜜播客。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析。
down the psychology of our 20s. If you have been a long time listener of the podcast, you will know that there is one TED Talk I reference probably three to four times a year and it's titled Your Elusive Creative Genius by Elizabeth Gilbert. This TED Talk entirely changed how I thought about success, how I thought about inspiration, failure and on a deeper level what it really meant to be human when Elizabeth or or Liz, as she is more commonly known as, released her book, Big Magic. It once again changed my life, and it is firmly one of my favorite, probably most read books
我们20年代的心理学。如果你一直是本播客的忠实听众，你就会知道有一个TED演讲我大概一年会引用三到四次，它的名字是伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（Elizabeth Gilbert）的《你难以捉摸的创作天才》（Your Elusive Creative Genius）。这个TED演讲彻底改变了我对成功的看法、对灵感的看法、对失败的看法，并在更深层次上改变了我对身为人类真正含义的理解。当伊丽莎白（或者Liz，人们更习惯这么叫她）出版她的书《大魔法》（Big Magic）时。它再次改变了我的生活，而且它毫无疑问是我最喜欢、大概也是我读过最多的书籍之一。
of all time. When I was first really getting listeners with the podcast back in 2021, someone asked me who my dream guest would be, and I said, Liz, because of that book, because of how incredible her mind is, because of all the books that she has since written, and all the wisdom that she really has to share. And it was a huge dream back in 2021, one that I really never thought was going to happen. But now in 2025, it's somehow finally come true. And I couldn't be more excited to have Liz on the podcast to discuss how to find our purpose, how to keep making and creating things, dealing with failure, managing success, and the best advice she has for people in
有史以来。当我在2021年刚开始让这个播客真正获得听众时，有人问我我的梦想嘉宾会是谁，我说，是莉兹（Liz），因为那本书，因为她那不可思议的思维，因为她自那以后写的所有书，以及她真正想要分享的所有智慧。在2021年，那是一个巨大的梦想，一个我真的从未想过会实现的梦想。但现在到了2025年，不知怎么地，它终于成真了。我无比激动地邀请莉兹来到播客，讨论如何找到我们的人生目标、如何继续制造和创造事物、如何应对失败、如何管理成功，以及她对。
20s. This episode is so very special to me and will forever have a place in my heart, but I also just hope you all enjoy it and you learn something. All right, without further ado, I want to welcome on Liz Gilbert to the show, to the psychology of your 20s. Liz, can you briefly introduce yourself and tell us about your work? Yes, first of all, I'm so happy to be here and honored to be here talking to you. My name is Liz Gilbert. I'm known, I guess, professionally as Elizabeth Gilbert, but that feels weird to introduce myself that way. I'm the author of Eat, Pray, Love, and Big Magic, and the signature of all things, and City of Girls, and a bunch of other books. And I also have, I'm a fiction and nonfiction author, but I also spend a lot of time
20年代年轻人最好的建议。这一集对我来说非常特别，将在我的心中永远占据一席之地，但我也希望你们所有人都能享受它并学到一些东西。好了，闲话少说，我想欢迎莉兹·吉尔伯特来到节目中，来到《20s的心理学》（the psychology of your 20s）。莉兹，你能简单自我介绍一下并给我们讲讲你的工作吗？好的，首先，我很高兴来到这里，也很荣幸能在这里与你交谈。我叫莉兹·吉尔伯特。我职业上大概被称为伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特，但这样介绍自己感觉有点奇怪。我是《一、祈祷、爱》（Eat, Pray, Love）、《大魔法》、《万物签名》（the signature of all things）、《女孩之城》（City of Girls）以及其他许多书的作者。我也有，我是一名小说和非小说类作家，但我花了很多时间。
teaching. And I don't teach writing, because I don't know how, but I teach a sort of general spirit of creativity, what I call creative living, a way of living where I simply define it this way, where you make your decisions based on your curiosity rather than your fear. And that ends up becoming a very creative life. So I'm sort of known also for that as being a teacher of creativity and kind of spirituality. That would be an amazing job title to have. A teacher. teacher of creativity and spirituality. Yeah. I'm like, all right.
进行教学。我教的不是写作，因为我不会，但我教的是一种普遍的创造力精神，我称之为创造性生活，一种我简单定义的生活方式，即你根据自己的好奇心而不是恐惧来做决定。这最终会成为一种非常有创造力的生活。所以我某种程度上也因这一点而闻名，作为创造力和某种精神层面的导师。那将是一个令人惊叹的头衔。一位导师。创造力和精神层面的导师。是的。我想，好吧。
So new career path unlocked. That sounds amazing. Great. Let's change the vision board up. I think I said this in my introduction, but most people know you for big magic, not for big magic, for eat pray love, probably. I think I was a little bit too young to really understand eat pray love. But I did really understand big magic.
所以新职业道路已解锁。听起来太棒了。太棒了。让我们换个愿景板。我想我在自我介绍时说过，但大多数人认识你可能是因为《一、祈祷、爱》，而不是《大魔法》。我想我当时有点太年轻了，无法真正理解《一、祈祷、爱》。但我确实真正理解了《大魔法》。
And it was just such a beautiful book that I continue to reference to this day. Do you remember, you know, in the interest of understanding purpose, do you remember when you kind of realized like, oh, I'm going to be a writer? I'm going to be this creative, curious person. This is my calling. Yeah. And I'm really glad you used the word calling because I would love to just launch in with some thoughts that I have about the word purpose and how much.
这是一本非常美丽的书，直到今天我还在不断引用它。你还记得，你知道的，为了理解人生目标，你是什么时候开始意识到“哦，我要成为一名作家”的？我要成为一个富有创造力、充满好奇心的人。这就是我的召唤。是的。我真的很高兴你用了“召唤”这个词，因为我很想直接从我对“purpose（目标/使命）”这个词的一些想法以及它带来了多少……
anxiety that word causes. Can we can we just start with that? Absolutely. Because it's obviously a lot of of people listening to this are like in their 20s and the amount of them that email me being like, I don't know what my purpose is. Oh, my God. Okay, let's get into it. Let's get into it. My honeies, my sweeties, you have been so terribly misinformed. This is my opinion. Everything I'm saying is my own opinion, take what you like and leave the rest, but I will throw out into the void and it will land on whoever it needs to land on, that there's this thing called purpose anxiety. And I scarcely know anybody who doesn't suffer from it. And I know some of the people who appear to be at the very, very, very top of a purpose driven life and have apparently achieved it. And they also
这个词引发的焦虑切入。我们能从这个开始吗？当然可以。因为很显然，许多听正收听这个节目的人都处在20年代，其中有大量的人发邮件给我说，我不知道我的人生目标是什么。噢，天哪。好吧，我们深入探讨吧。我们深入探讨吧。我的宝贝们，我的甜心们，你们被严重地误导了。这是我的观点。我所说的一切都只是我个人的观点，取你所需，其余的随它去吧，但我会把这些抛向虚空，它会降落在任何需要它的人身上，那就是有一种东西叫做“目标焦虑”。我几乎不认识谁不为之所苦。而且我认识一些似乎正处于目标驱动型生活的最顶峰、并且显然已经实现这一点的人。他们也。
still suffer from purpose anxiety. And the reason that everybody suffers from purpose anxiety is because everyone in Western contemporary culture has been told this same theology. And it really is a theology. And you've been told variants of this from the time you were born and you've heard it in every graduation and commencement speech and in every self-help book. And no one has ever questioned whether it even makes sense or whether it is even true. But here is the theology. Everyone is born with a unique purpose that is completely, their own and totally unrelated to anybody else. It's one thing that only you can do, nobody but you can do it.
仍然饱受目标焦虑的折磨。每个人之所以都遭受目标焦虑的折磨，是因为西方当代文化中的每个人都被灌输了同一种神学。这真的就是一种神学。你从出生起就被灌输了这种观念的变体，你在每一次毕业典礼和开学演讲中、在每一本自助书里都听过它。从来没有人质疑过它到底有没有道理，甚至它是不是真的。但这就是这种神学。每个人出生时都带着一个独特的使命，这个使命完全属于他们自己，与任何人毫无关系。这是只有你能做的一件事，除了你没人能做到。
So already that creates anxiety in me because there's 8 billion people on the planet. And so what? I'm supposed to find something in me that is that no one else can do. Like that doesn't, the math don't even add up on that, right? And you should, you should know it from the time that you're born. And you should always know what it is. It should be extremely. extremely clear what it is. And then your job is to devote your entire life to that one thing. And if you miss the boat and it's too late and you haven't gotten on that, you should be extremely anxious and ashamed of yourself that you don't know what it is. I mean, this is what people are taught. And then you must become the master of that thing. You must devote an
所以这已经在我的心中制造了焦虑，因为星球上有80亿人口。然后呢？我本应在自己身上找到一样东西，是其他人做不到的。这根本，连数学逻辑上都说不通，对吧？而且你应该，你应该从出生起就知道这一点。并且你应该始终清楚它是什么。它应该极其。极其清楚它是什么。然后你的工作就是把你的整个一生奉献给那唯一的事情。如果你错失良机，而且为时已晚，你还没有走上那条路，你就应该感到极其焦虑，并为自己不知道它是什么而感到羞耻。我的意思是，这就是人们被教导的。然后你必须成为那件事的大师。你必须投入。
enormous amount of time, attention, and money to mastering whatever that thing is, that unique spark that nobody else has. And then you must monetize it. Because if you make your money, doing anything other than the thing that is your unique spark and purpose, then you are a failure. And it's not enough that you must monetize it. You must become the best at it. And you must also create opportunity for others. And you must then change the world through your purpose. This is what literally everybody is told. And no wonder, everybody is full of anxiety about it. And I mean, if we can just break it down for a minute, it's, first of all, it comes from a place of enormous, hubris and arrogance to
付出大量的时间、注意力和金钱去精通任何那件事，那个别人没有的独特火花。然后你必须将其实现商业化。因为如果你赚钱，做的不是那个作为你独特火花和使命的事情，那么你就是一个失败者。而且仅仅将其实现商业化还不够。你必须成为其中的佼佼者。你还必须为他人创造机会。然后你必须通过你的使命改变世界。字面意思上，这就是所有人被告知的。难怪，每个人都对此充满了焦虑。我的意思是，如果我们能花一点时间把它剖析开来，首先，这源于一种极其自大和傲慢的心态。
pretend to believe like to think that you can know what you are here for when we don't even know what this is this planet consciousness this experience like we don't even know we literally have no idea
假装认为——去认为你可以知道你来到这里是为了什么，当我们甚至不知道这是什么：这个星球、意识、这种体验——就像我们甚至不知道，我们字面意思上毫无头脑。
what's going on and like why your soul was dropped into your particular body and born into your like we can't know and anybody who pretends that they know you should be very suspicious of them so there's an enormous arrogance. Also, can you hear how self-centered it is? Purpose theology comes from Western men. And so it's all about, I have to be incredibly important. I actually have to be the most important. And I have to
发生了什么，以及为什么你的灵魂会被抛入你特定的身体并出生在你的——我们无从得知，而任何假装自己知道的人，你都应该对他们保持高度怀疑，所以这是一种巨大的傲慢。而且，你能听到它是多么以自我为中心吗？目标神学（Purpose theology）是由西方男性提出的。所以这一切都是关于：我必须极其重要。我实际上必须是最重要的。而且我必须。
change the world in my own image. And this whole idea, even that you have to change the world, there's a tremendous arrogance in that too, because I think at this point, if you look around the planet, the world is pretty clearly saying, like, I wish you people would stop changing me. Yeah. It's saying like you've done enough. You've done enough. And the people have led the most purpose-driven lives are the people who have perhaps done the most damage to the planet and to other people. So everything about it is so distorted. And all it does is cause people to suffer. And I've met the people who are living at the top of that game. And they are not relaxed. They are not at peace. And they never know whether they've done enough. Have they changed the world enough? Have they made it a big enough impact. Oh, and if you're thinking, great, I can't wait to die because then
以我自己的形象改变世界。甚至连你必须改变世界这种整体想法，里面也有着巨大的傲慢，因为我认为在这一点上，如果你环顾这个星球，世界非常清楚地在表达：我希望你们这些人类停止改变我。是的。它在表达：你们已经做得够多了。你们做得够多了。而那些过着最具目标驱动型生活的人，或许正是对地球和他人造成最大破坏的人。所以这一切都是如此扭曲。而它所做的一切，就是让人类遭受痛苦。我见过那些处于那个游戏顶峰的人。他们并不放松。他们并不平静。他们永远不知道自己是否做得够多。他们是否足够改变了世界？他们是否产生了足够大的影响。哦，如果你在想：太好了，我迫不及待地想死，因为这样。
this whole purpose anxiety thing will be over, you're also supposed to leave a legacy. Right. So it like never ends. The self-centeredness, the arrogance and the anxiety of purpose theology never end. So what I am gently here to offer as a counterpoint to a purpose driven life is a life of presence. Because the other thing about a purpose-driven life is that it constantly has you in the future. You can't live a purpose-driven, anxiety-driven theology without always being locked in the future of like, who am I going to become, what am I going to do, what is my impact going to be, who am I going to affect? And you completely miss life. You completely miss life. I mean, my favorite spiritual teacher, Byron Katie, says, if you want to suffer, get a future.
这种宏大的目标焦虑就会结束了，你还得留下遗产。对吧。所以它就像永无止境一样。目标神学的以自我为中心、傲慢和焦虑永无止境。所以，我在这里温和地作为一个反对观点来提供给目标驱动型生活的，是一种活在当下的生活。因为目标驱动型生活的另一面是，它总是让你活在未来。你不可能过着一种目标驱动的、焦虑驱动的神学生活，却不总是被锁在未来之中，比如：我将成为谁，我要做什么，我的影响会是什么，我会影响谁？而你完全错过了生活。你完全错过了生活。我的意思是，我最喜欢的精神导师拜伦·凯蒂（Byron Katie）说：如果你想受苦，那就去关注未来。
So this obsession with the future will bring you nothing but pain. So the contrary position to take is a life of presence, which is simply being a witness to the extraordinary, unknowable, miraculous strangeness of being a human being on this planet and observing it and being like, this is so, I mean, because it is objectively interesting. It's not safe this planet. It never has been for people, but it's a really interesting experience. It definitely is. It's a really interesting experience to be who you are in your culture that you were dropped in at this moment of history.
所以这种对未来的执念除了痛苦什么都不会带给你。因此，要采取的相反立场是一种活在当下的生活，也就是简单地作为一个见证者，去见证作为这个星球上的一个人类那非凡的、不可知、神奇而怪异的存在，去观察它并感叹：这太——我的意思是，因为它客观上很有趣。这个星球并不安全。对人类而言从未安全过，但这确实是一个非常有趣的体验。它绝对是。作为一个身处你被抛入的历史时刻的文化中的你，是一种非常有趣的体验。
And I think that experience itself would like a few people to relax and observe it and actually be like, this is wild. Like this is absolutely wild. and I don't know what I am, and I don't know who I am, and I don't know where I'm going, and I don't know what I'm supposed to be doing, but it is very interesting to be here. And if you start from that perspective and you begin to follow the track of your curiosity of what's most interesting, you will have an interesting life. You may not have a life that certain kinds of people would look at, and say is successful, but I'm not interested in those kinds of people.
我认为这种体验本身，会希望少数人能放松下来去观察它并真正感叹：这太疯狂了。这绝对是疯狂的。我不知道我是什么，我不知道我是谁，我不知道我要去哪里，我也不知道我应该在做什么，但来到这里非常有趣。如果你从那个视角出发，并开始追踪你的好奇心轨迹——什么是最有趣的，你就会拥有一个有趣的生活。你可能不会过上那种特定类型的人看了会说“成功”的生活，但我对那种类型的人不感兴趣。
They're not part of the conversation. I have a friend who says, everybody's got a brother-in-law named Phil who's like, yeah, but what are you doing? Like, what are you doing for your job? Like, what's your plan? Like, must be nice to take, you know, must be nice to, you know, like, just everyone's got that in their life. And Phil must be ignored.
他们不属于这场对话。我有个朋友说：每个人都有一个叫菲尔（Phil）的姐夫，他会说：“对啊，但你在做什么？比如，你的工作是什么？比如，你的计划是什么？像，拿……一定很爽吧，你知道的，一定很爽吧，你知道的，就像……”每个人生活中都有这样的人。而菲尔必须被忽略。
Phil must be ignored. It's so funny. Like, I see this on social media all the time. where it's like often some young woman or young man like exploring some creative side of them making art posting just for fun whatever it is writing just for fun and there's always someone in the comments being like must be nice not to have work a full-time job like must be nice to take a break and I'm like well yeah it is really nice I'm sure it is really nice for them to do that in fact it is thank you it's lovely in fact it's lovely like I get it all the time with people like people will come
菲尔必须被忽略。这太搞笑了。就像，我在社交媒体上经常看到这种现象。通常是一些年轻女性或年轻男性，在探索他们富有创造力的一面，创作艺术，纯粹为了好玩而发帖，无论是什么，纯粹为了好玩而写作，评论区里总会有人说：不用做全职工作一定很爽吧，休息一下一定很爽吧，而我就会想：好吧，是的，确实很爽。我确信对他们来说这真的很爽，事实上真的很棒，谢谢你，这很可爱，事实上真的很迷人。比如我经常遇到这种人，人们会偶然。
across like the podcast and come across like my online presence and we'll be like wow you call that work you call that whatever like and get really upset with me and i'm like honestly all i'm hearing there is a desire to have what i have like you think that your reality of needing to prove yourself and work hard and never take a day off and always be like thinking about your family and thinking about everyone else like that doesn't actually sound particularly desirable so i often like that's how i try and treat it. I'm like I just feel kind of bad for those people who were raised again with the theology that you have one purpose and if you haven't found it bad luck, time to be miserable and just work the nine to five. You have wasted your life. Yeah. It also treats life rather than being a
看到播客，看到我在网上的存在，然后就会说：哇，你管这叫工作？你管这叫什么……然后对我非常生气，而我就会想：老实说，我从中听到的全部只是一种渴望，想要拥有我所拥有的东西——你认为你需要证明自己、努力工作、从不休息、总是想着你的家庭和每个人的现实——那听觉上其实并不是特别令人向往的，所以我经常像——这就是我试图对待它的方式。我只是对那些再次被灌输了“你只有一个使命，如果你没找到它那就倒霉、该去受苦并老老实实上九晚五班”这种神学观念的人感到有点遗憾。你已经浪费了你的人生。是的。它对待生命的方式，不是将其视为一个。
miraculous, mysterious, unknowable gift. It treats it as something that must be earned that you must earn your place. You must earn your right to be here. And, And whatever created you doesn't seem to think so because it just dropped you here. It didn't seem to think you had to earn your right to be here. And, you know, I also, I would love to just take a moment and talk about these four different things that people often amalgamate into one thing. And that also causes anxiety. And the four things are hobby, job, career, and calling.
奇迹般的、神秘的、不可知的礼物。它把生命当作某种必须靠努力赢得的东西，你必须赢得你的地位。你必须赢得你呆在这里的权利。而且，无论是什么创造了你，似乎并不这么认为，因为它只是把你抛到了这里。它似乎并不认为你必须赢得留在这里的权利。而且，你知道，我也，我很想花一点时间来谈谈这四件常常被人们混为一谈的不同事情。这也是焦虑的根源。这四件事是：业余爱好、工作、职业和天职（calling）。
So I just want to take a moment and distinguish between these four things. Okay, so a hobby is something that you do because it's fun and you like it. And that's the thing that you post on social media. People are like, must be nice to take a pottery class. Yeah, it is nice. And hobbies actually bring an end to anxiety, like puttering about, making things for no reason, doing something simply because it's a pleasure until very recently everyone had hobbies. And most of life was just people doing stuff because they liked doing it and it was fun. and it doesn't have to be monetized.
所以我只想花一点时间来区分这四件事。好吧，业余爱好是你做的事情，因为这很有趣，你喜欢它。这就是你发到社交媒体上的东西。人们会说：上个陶艺课一定很爽吧。对，确实很爽。业余爱好实际上能消除焦虑，比如东摸摸西搞搞、无缘无故地做点东西、纯粹因为开心而做某事——直到不久前，每个人都有业余爱好。而大部分的生活不过是人们做事情，因为他们喜欢做，而且这很有趣。并且它不需要被商业化。
You don't have to be the best at it. You don't have to become famous at it. My biggest suggestion to people who are in purpose, anxieties, is to get a hobby that has absolutely no connection to anything productive and enjoy it because life is also meant to be enjoyed. So that's a hobby. A job. A job is a thing that unless you are a trust fund baby or landed gentry, you have to have.
你不需要成为其中的佼佼者。你不需要因此成名。我对处于目标焦虑中的人们最大的建议是：去培养一个与任何生产力都完全没有关系的爱好，然后享受它，因为生活本来就是用来享受的。所以，这是一个爱好。一份工作。工作是一件这样的事：除非你是个信托基金宝贝（trust fund baby）或拥有土地的乡绅，否则你不得不去做。
But here's the thing. You don't have to like it. Like I've had so many jobs in my life that I've done. didn't like, you don't have to like it. It doesn't have to be your purpose. You don't have to be great at it. You don't have to come. It doesn't have to consume your entire life. It's just a thing you have to do to make some money so that you can go home and have hobbies. Right. I love that. I love that way of thinking about it. Get a job. You know, just get a job. It doesn't like, like, and you, it's like, don't give your heart to it. Deliver 30% at work.
但关键在于。你不需要喜欢它。就像我生命中做过那么多工作。我不喜欢，你不需要喜欢它。它不必是你的使命。你不需要在这方面表现卓越。你不需要来。它不必消耗你的整个生活。它只是你为了赚点钱而不得不做的事，这样你就能回家去享受爱好。没错。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这种思考方式。去找份工作。你知道，就去找份工作。它不需要像——就像你，这就好像：别把你的真心交出去。在工作中交付30%就行了。
You know, like they'll never know. Like a job is a place where you can go and just phone it in and they'll never know. Yeah. I always say to people, I'm always like just act, act your wage. Like, act your wage. Like if you're getting paid minimum wage, exactly. Like, if you're getting paid minimum wage, minimum work. And this goes totally against capitalism, purpose, anxiety to say that in theology, but just show up, do the least you can do to get your, to keep your job and then have your life be outside of your job with the things that you're curious about, the things that you enjoy, the people that you like being with. So that's a job. It's not the same as a hobby. The next thing is a career. So a career is a job that you're passionate about. Right. That's all a career is. Don't act like your
你知道的，就像他们永远不会发现一样。工作就是一个你可以去敷衍了事、而他们永远不会发现的地方。是的。我总是对人们说，我总是说：拿多少钱，演多少戏。就像：拿多少钱，演多少戏。如果你拿的是最低工资，没错。就像，如果你拿的是最低工资，就付出最低限度的工作。这完全违背了资本主义和目标焦虑，在神学里说出这样的话，但只要出勤，做你能做的最少的事来保住你的工作，然后让你的生活在工作之外展开，去做那些让你充满好奇的事、你享受的事、你喜欢和他们在一起的人。所以，这是一份工作。它跟业余爱好不一样。接下来是一项职业（career）。所以，职业是一份你充满热情的“工作”。没错。职业就是这样。如果你对它没有热情，就别把你的工作当成你的职业。就像，如果你只是觉得“这只是我的工作”，那就别试图把工作变成职业。但如果你对它充满热情，并且觉得这就是我来这里要做的事，我正以这种方式服务全人类，那么你就会全身心投入到你的工作中。所以，职业是一份让你全身心投入的工作，因为它带给你如此多的爱和满足感。而且无论他们付你多少钱都无所谓。你无论如何都想去做。而且你确实会为了职业全力以赴。但你并不一定非得有一项职业。就像你必须有一份工作，但你不需要有一项职业。如果你身处一项职业却并不热爱它，你应该辞职去找份工作。
job is your career if you're not passionate about it. Like don't try to make a job into a career if you're just like, this is just my job, you know? But if you are passionate about it and you feel like this is what I'm here to do and I'm here to serve humanity in this way, then you pour yourself into your job. So a career is a job that you pour yourself into because it brings you so much love and satisfaction. And it doesn't even matter how much they pay you. You would want to do it anyway. And like you really do show up for a career. But you don't have to have a career. Like you do have to have a job, but you don't have to have a career. And if you are in a career and you don't love it, you should quit and get a job.
就像，如果你的职业正在毁掉你的生活，那就去换个工作。有很多工作。去找份工作，然后去培养爱好，再去交朋友。最后一件事情就是天职（calling）。天职是你觉得情不自禁非做不可的事，因为这是一种精神上的满足。并不是每个人都有天职。并不是每个人都需要有天职。
Like if your career is destroying your life, just go get a job. There's lots of jobs. Just go get a job and then have hobbies and then have friends. And then the final thing is a calling. And a calling is something that you feel you are compelled to do because it's a spiritual fulfillment. And not everybody has one. and not everybody needs to have one.
如果你有天职，你自然会知道，因为你已经拥有它了。如果你没有，你也不必大老远地出去寻找，因为别担心。这是你无法创造的东西。你无法创造一个天职。要么是更高的力量给了你一个，要么就是没有。也许以后会来一个，也许不会。所以你可以为此完全放松。如果你有一个天职，那么你就全身心地投入其中，这与你是否获得报酬完全没有关系。
And if you have one, you'll know because you already have it. And if you don't have one, you don't have to go out there searching for it because don't worry about it. It's something you can't create. You can't create a calling. You either like higher power gave you one or didn't. And maybe one will come later or maybe it won't. So you can just relax about it. And if you've got a calling, then you devote yourself to it and it's got absolutely nothing to do with whether you're being paid or not.
而且没有人能把它从你身边夺走。我可以失去我的职业。所以我的天职是成为一名作家。自我9岁起我就知道了。但在我30岁之前，它并不是我的职业。但在它成为我的职业之前的整个时期里，它都是我的天职。所以我一边打工维持生计，一边做着我的天职。没有人要求我这么做。
And no one can ever take it away from you. I can lose my career. So my calling is to be a writer. and I knew that ever since I was nine years old. But it wasn't my career until I was 30. But through that entire time before it became my career, it was my calling. So I did it while I had jobs, I did my calling. Nobody wanted me to do it.
没有人付钱让我这么做。没有人对我有兴趣去做这件事感兴趣。随着时间的推移，它变成了我的职业。我的职业可以被毁掉。人工智能可以夺走我的职业。人们可以解雇我。世界可以决定不再想读伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特的书了。
Nobody paid me to do it. Nobody was interested in me doing it. And then over time, it became my career. My career can be destroyed. AI can take my career away. people can fire me. The world can decide it doesn't want to read Elizabeth Gilbert Gilbert books anymore.
有很多方法可以让我失去我的职业。我无法控制这一点，对此我很清楚。如果我有一天失去了我的职业，我会直接去找个工作，然后重回拥有业余爱好的生活。但没有人能夺走我的天职。当我想写作时，没有人能阻止我写作，即使当时没人付钱给我。如果我的职业破产了，现在也没有人能阻止我写作。这就是业余爱好。
Like there are so many ways I can lose my career. I'm not in control of that and I'm aware of that. And if I ever lose my career, I'll just go get a job and go back to having hobbies. But nobody can take my calling away. Nobody could stop me from writing when I wanted to write, even though they weren't paying me to. And nobody can stop me from writing now if my career folds. So that's the difference between a hobby.
工作、天职和职业之间的区别。知道这些区别非常重要，因为我们生活在一个将它们全部混为一谈、并告诉你应该拥有一件包含所有这些东西的事物的文化中。而事实并非如此。所以我只想为所有人澄清这一点。老实说，我能感觉到人们身上的焦虑此刻正在消散，因为这大概是我收到的最大的一系列/两难的问题，那就是：我如何知道？我命中注定要做什么？我如何在两份工作中做出选择，一份我更有热情，一份我热情较少？我如何找回对生活的热情？老实说，我认为很多问题都可以归结为对这四种截然不同的区分。
a job, a calling, and a career. And it's so important to know the difference because we live in a culture that has pushed them all together and said that you should have one thing that's all of that. And it isn't true. So I just want to just clarify that for everybody. I can honestly feel the anxiety fading from people right now because that is probably the biggest series slash dilemma of questions that I get, which is how do I know what? I'm meant to do? How do I choose between these two jobs that one I'm more passionate about, one I'm less passionate about? How do I, you know, get the spark back for life? And honestly, I think a lot of the questions come back to that distinction between these four very distinct
当你仔细想想，它们是存在的范畴和生存的范畴。事实上，当我刚开始做播客时，情况非常相似。就像，这是一种奇怪的事情，我只是知道这就是我命中注定要做的事。这是一个天职。而我当时真的一个听众都没有。我在我的汽车后座上录制。我总是讲那个故事，在前几期节目中，你字面意思上可以听到卡车开过的声音。你可以听到背景中的鸟叫声，因为我是用手机录音的。谁听其实根本不重要。我只是觉得我必须去做。你的书里有一个类比。在你的TED演讲中也有提到，关于一个想法有时会直接落入你的怀抱，你有点不得不与它签订契约，它就像凭空出现一样，
when you think about it categories of being and categories of existing. I actually, when I first started the podcast, it was very similar. Like, it was this weird thing where I just knew that this is what I was meant to do. It was a calling. And I genuinely had no listeners. I recorded it in the back of my car. And I always tell the story of like in the first episodes, you can literally hear like trucks going by. You can hear birds in the background because I'm recording it on my phone. And it really didn't matter who listened. I just felt like I had to do it. There's an analogy that you have in your book. And also in your TED talk about how an idea will sometimes just be dropped in your lap and you kind of have to make a contract with it. And it kind of appears out of nowhere,
对吧？就像：噢，噢天哪，我刚刚有了一个绝妙的主意。某种精神把它赐予了我。风向改变了，把它带给了我。我太喜欢你说的了：无论它是什么，它都在试图找到那个将把它变为现实的人。就像它会试图找到最好的载体让它成为现实。老实说，对于《20s的心理学》，我也是这种感觉。就像，人们问我这个创意是怎么来的，而我会说：我真的毫无头脑。就像我毫无头脑。它就那么找上了我，而我知道我必须去做它。但我确实认为，当我开始赚钱、当它真正成为支付我的账单、允许我——你知道的，它变成了一份工作、一个爱好、一份职业和一项天职，所有这一切都集于一身时，我与它的关系发生了变化。
right? And it's just like, oh, oh my God, I've just had this brilliant idea. Some spirit has given it to me. The wind has shifted and brought it to me. And I just love how you say it's like, whatever it is is trying to find the person who's going to make it reality. Like it's going to try and find the best conduit for it to be real. And I honestly felt that about the psychology of your 20s. It was like, people ask me how I came up with the idea. And I'm like, I genuinely have no idea. Like I have no idea. It just came to me and I just knew I had to do it. But I do think that my relationship with it changed when I started making money and when it did become the thing that paid my bills that allowed me, you know, it became a job, a hobby, a career and a calling all it was.
我确信对于你来说，写作也是如此。百分之百。当那种转变发生时，当动力。完全转变时，发生了什么？好吧，是的，当金钱介入时，一切都改变了。并不是说我反感金钱。我很高兴能靠做这个谋生。我认为我必须拥有的、非常重要的一点，而且我必须在整个职业生涯中一直坚持这一点，
And I'm sure that was probably the case with writing for you as well. 100%. What happened when that shifted, when the dynamic, shifted entirely? Well, yeah, when money is introduced, it changes everything. And it's not that I'm anti-money. I'm very delighted that I can make my living doing this. I think the really important thing that I have, that I've had to remember, and I've had to carry this through my entire career,
是，好吧，我的意思是，无论你的职业是什么，这都是真的。我只是在想，无论你在做什么，这其实都是事实，无论你是一个土木工程师还是一个画家。就像，没有什么是保证的。你知道，没有什么是保证的，也没有人欠你什么。没有任何地方存在某种契约——无论是社会契约还是精神契约——说你被保证了这一切。你可以，你知道的，就像“这一切会继续”或者“你被允许拥有这个，你知道的，
is that, well, I mean, it doesn't matter what your career is this. I'm just thinking this is actually the truth, no matter what you're doing, whether you're a civil engineer or a painter. Like it doesn't, you know, nothing is promised. You know, nothing is promised and nothing is owed. Nowhere was there some sort of contract, either a social contract or a spiritual contract that said, you're assured this. You get to, you know, like this will continue or you're allowed to have this like, you know,
我们看到社会的崩解和广播联盟的瓦解。这些都不是保证的。你可以为此感到愤怒，或者你可以对此持一种道家的态度，顺应现实能量的流动。有一句美丽的台词，我一直引以为戒，它出自《薄伽梵歌》（Bhagavad Gita），这是一部古老的印度印度教灵修经典。里面有一句台词，其中一位神明对其中一位英雄说：你享有劳动的权利，但你不享有劳动成果的权利。
we're seeing that as societies are breaking down in unions of radio. None of this is promised. And you can get angry about that or you can just be a Taoist about it and sort of just go with the flow of energy of reality. And there's a beautiful line that I quote to myself all the time that's from the Bhagavagata Gita, which is this ancient Indian Hindu spiritual text. And there's a line in there where one of the gods says to one of the heroes, you are entitled to the labor, but you are not entitled to the fruit of the labor.
这句话对于现代人来说很难落地，因为我们有很多的优越感和理所当然感。这就好比：嗯，我真的很努力。我应该。我真的很努力。因此我应该得到这个。这就是资本主义的微积分。你知道，就像：我努力了，因此我应该拥有这个。
And that is something that is hard to land on modern years because we have a lot of sense of entitlement. And it's like, well, I worked really hard. I should. I worked really hard. I therefore should. That's the calculus of capitalism. You know, like, I worked hard and therefore I should have this.
而地球上生活的实际现实是。没有人告诉你那是真的。我的意思是，有些不知道世界如何运作的人确实对你这么说过。世界实际运作的方式是：它耸耸肩。这就好像世界，你知道，宇宙有点无动于衷。你知道，宇宙有点像：也许你会拥有它，也许你不会。也许你会拥有它一会儿。也许你不会。
And the actual reality of life on earth is. nobody told you that that's true. I mean, some people told you that who don't know how the world works. The way the world actually works is like it shrugs. It's like the world, you know, the universe is a little bit indifferent. You know, the universe is a little bit like, maybe you'll have it, maybe you won't. Maybe you'll have it for a while. Maybe you won't.
你知道，就像我喜欢古典印度神学和对神的观念中的那种态度：神与其说是一个讲道理的统治法官，不如说是一个住在山顶上、有点半老痴呆、手里有钱、然后把钱给了一些不配得到的人、又给了其他配得到的人的老太太，你知道的，她做出承诺却不兑现，而且有点神志不清。就像，这才是生活的实际现实，你知道的。所以我并不理所当然。我并不理所当然。我的书曾被取消出版。你知道，就像我有。我有。一本书在两年前刚要出版前就被取消了，你知道的，当时的感觉就像：哇，我可能会为此崩溃，然后觉得：我在这上面花了四年时间。对我来说这是一个悲剧。
You know, like I love that about like the sort of classical Indian theology and ideas of God is like, God is much less a sort of reasonable reigning judge than a kind of baddy old lady who lives on the top of a hill and has money and gives it to some people who don't deserve it and gives it to other people who do, you know, and makes promises and doesn't keep them and is a little bit senile. And it's like, that's the actual reality of life, you know. And so I'm not entitled. I'm not entitled. I've had books canceled. You know, like I had A. I had A. book canceled two years ago right before it was published, you know, and it was like, wow, I could freak out about this and be like, I worked for four years on this. This is a tragedy for me
这本书竟然没能出版。或者我可以顺应现实生活，然后觉得：嗯，这很有趣。这件事情发生得真是客观上有趣。这并不是我预料中的。我认为生活的大部分内容其实就是：这不是我预料中的。这很有趣。生活在焦虑之中和生活在创造力之中的区别。我的朋友玛莎·贝克（Martha Beck）最近写了一本关于“焦虑的解药、焦虑的对立面不是放松，而是创造力”的书。创造力是摆脱焦虑的唯一出路。而进入创造力的唯一途径，就是带着一种“这真有趣”的精神去生活，
that this book isn't being published. Or I can live in accordance with reality and be like, well, that's interesting. That is objectively interesting that that happened. That is not what I expected. I think so much of life is just that is not what I expected. That's interesting. And the difference between living a life of anxiety and living a life of creativity. And my friend Martha Beck just recently wrote a book about how the antidote for anxiety, the opposite of anxiety, is not relaxation, it's creativity. It's creativity is the only way out of anxiety. And the only way into creativity is to live from a spirit of, that's interesting,
而不是带着一种“这真是个噩梦”的精神。这也是一种没有戏剧性的生活。从诸如“这真有趣”的视角生活。噢，一个我以为我要嫁给他的跟我分手了。这真有趣。哇，我真的很想要孩子，但我不能生。这真的很有趣。我世上最爱的人、我以为会永远作为我精神支柱的人去世了。
rather than a spirit of like, what a nightmare. It's also a drama-free life. To live from a place of like, that's interesting. Oh, somebody broke up with me who I thought I was going to marry. That is interesting. Wow, I really wanted kids and I can't have them. That is really interesting. The person I loved the most in the world died who I thought was going to be like my anchor forever.
这真有趣。你知道，这太有趣了。我接下来该怎么办？所以在人生的电子游戏里，我下一步该怎么走？如果你想过一种没有太多焦虑的生活，下一步就是：现在我能做的最有趣的事情是什么？我也很喜欢一句非常平等的名言，那就是：焦虑的对立面是信任。我认为这也在这里发挥了作用，你可以遭遇——像最糟糕、最可怕的情况。
That's interesting. You know, that is so interesting. What am I going to do now? So on the video game of life, like what is my next move? And the next move, if you want to have a life without a lot of anxiety, is what would be the most interesting thing I could do now? I also love a very equal quote, which is the opposite of anxiety is trust. And I think that also comes into play here, where you can be thrown like the most awful,
但如果你相信你能挺过去，如果你相信自己有能力找到一条出路，或者找到一条通往你真正热爱、想要的生活的路，你大多数时候都能挺过去。就像自我信任简直——我不知道，它简直是太多东西的解药了。它是战胜冒名顶替综合症的解药。
terrible circumstances. But if you trust that you are going to make it through, and if you trust that you are capable of finding a root out, or finding your way back to a life that you really love and that you want, you will make it through most of the time. Like self-trust is just such like, I don't know, it's just such an antidote to so much. It's an antidote to imposter syndrome.
它是对抗大量焦虑的解药。我真的很想联系到你之前所说的话，关于：上帝，宇宙就像一个住在山顶上的老太太，只是在散发金钱。因为我在很多20多岁的年轻人身上经常看到这一点，那就是：如果我付出X数量的努力，我就会获得Y数量的回报。我总是把这放在人们为考试复习的语境中去思考，对吧？在这个十年里你经常做的一件事。
It's an antidote to a lot of anxiety. And I really want to link back to what you were saying before of, you know, God, the universe is somebody or lady like living on the top of a hill, just giving out money. Because I see this a lot with people in their 20s where it's like, if I work X amount of hard, I will receive Y amount of reward. And I always think about it in the context of people studying for exams, right? Very common thing that you do during this decade.
某个人可能跟你学习了完全相同的课时，拥有完全相同的复习内容，却得到了完全不同的成绩，对内容的理解也完全不同。有时甚至——某个人可能比你少学很多，却拿到了好得多的成绩。是的。完全正确。这就好像：好吧。所以我们都以为这只是靠努力工作。而这实际上是我不得不真正接受的一件事，当时我想：
Someone could study the exact same amount of hours of you as you have the exact same content and get a completely different grade, could understand it completely differently. And sometimes like somebody could study a lot less than you and get a much better grade. Yeah. Exactly. And it's like, okay. So we all think that it's just hard work. And it was actually something I had to really accept where I was like,
这里面有一点运气成分也是可以的。这其实没关系。是的。而我一直很担心。我会想：嗯，运气不是。运气是没有保证的。所以如果我的生活是靠运气赐予我的——一旦局势逆转，
it's okay for a bit of this to be luck. Like it's actually okay. Yeah. And I kept worrying. I'd be like, well, luck isn't, luck isn't promised. So if my life has been given to me by luck, like as soon as the table's turn,
我可能就无法再拥有我的生活了。所以我打算把努力工作当作一份保险。最终你不得不有点放手，因为它会让你觉得你做的每一件事都与你有多渴望它、你有多想要它、
I could not have my life anymore. So I'm going to use hard work as an insurance. And eventually you have to kind of let that go because it makes you feel like every single thing that you do is tied to how much you want it and how much you want it. and how many hours you're willing to put into it, which is not true. It's just simply not true.
以及你愿意投入多少小时直接挂钩，而这并不是真的。这根本不是真的。
It's all based on the devastating wish that life would be fair and sensible. And there's very little evidence that I have seen to support that it is either of those things. But it is, once again, interesting. The baddy old lady who lives on the top of the hill who's half senile and holds all sorts of power and forgets your name, like promises you an inheritance and then forgets your name. Yeah. It's like I already gave it to that person. I'm sorry, give it to the gardener.
这一切都建立在一种毁灭性的愿望之上，即希望生活是公平和通情达理的。而我几乎没有看到任何证据支持它是这两者中的任何一个。但它，再次重申，很有趣。住在山顶上那个半老痴呆、掌握着各种权力的老太太，忘了你的名字，就像许诺给你一笔遗产然后又忘了你的名字。是的。这就好像：我明明已经把那笔钱给那个人了。对不起，给园丁吧。
Like I thought, you know, like, wait, but I'm your grandchild. Well, are you? You know, like, it's so, and this is why I think that the manifestation theology is a bit dangerous. This idea, you made a sort of joke about vision boards and vision boards can be really sweet. And there is something about that. There is a, it's not that you're helpless. There is a, there's a push and a pull. There's a part that you have control over and there's a part that you don't.
就像我以为，你知道，等等，但我才是你的孙子。哦，是吗？你知道，这太……这就是为什么我认为显化神学（manifestation theology）有点危险。这种想法，你刚才开了个关于愿景板（vision boards）的玩笑，愿景板其实挺可爱的。而且这其中确实有些道理。这并不是说你束手无策。这里有一种推动，也有拉扯。有一部分你可以控制，而有一部分你无法控制。
And the way I describe it to eat, pray, It's like a circus, trained circus acrobat riding on two horses at the same time. You know, like one foot on two horses around a ring. And the play that I feel in my own life between my own will and what can only be called destiny or fate is I've only got a foot on one of those horses. You know, and the other one, it looks like it's running right alongside me. But at any moment, anything could happen, you know, like anything could happen that changes the game. And how do we hold our equanimity? And they're both running at full speed, by the way.
我是这样形容《一、祈祷、爱》的，这就像是一个马戏团，一个受过训练的马戏团杂技演员同时骑两匹马。你知道的，就像一只脚踩在环绕竞技场的两匹马上。而在我自己的生活中，我自己的意愿与只能被称为命运或天意的东西之间，那种博弈的感觉是，我只有一只脚踩在其中一匹马上。你知道的，而另一匹，看起来它就紧紧跑在我旁边。但随时随地，任何事情都可能发生，你知道的，就像任何事情都可能发生，从而改变整个局势。我们又该如何保持内心的平静？顺便说一句，它们都在全速奔跑。
You know? And the really good acrobats are the ones who are just like, and they're sparkly, in their sparkly, leotard with a big smile. And a plume of, like, here we are. We're on the ride, you know. So it's, yeah, but there's, there is no promised outcome. The outcome is not promised. You're entitled to the labor, but you're not entitled to the fruit of the labor.
你知道吗？那些真正优秀的杂技演员，他们就是那种，而且他们闪闪发光，穿着闪亮的紧身衣，带着灿烂的笑容。带着一束，就像，我们来啦。我们在享受这段旅程，你知道的。所以，是的，但是，并没有所谓的承诺结局。结局是没有承诺的。你只享有劳动的权利，但不享有劳动成果的权利。
And if, gosh, if there's one thing that could make, you happier than anything else it would be to release any sense of entitlement to anything. Because the most depressed, outraged and anxious that I have been in my life has been when I didn't get what I want. And I had to suffer through some sort of a tantrum about it for however amount of time until I surrendered to, you ain't getting it. Don't matter how much you want it. You cannot make that person love. you. You cannot make that person love you. You cannot change the past. You cannot change people's opinions. You can't. And so I think the reason I'm a lot more serene in my 50s than I was in my 20s
如果，天哪，如果有什么事能比其他任何事都更能让你感到快乐，那就是放下对任何事情的理所当然感。因为在我一生中，我感到最沮丧、愤怒和焦虑的时刻，就是我没有得到我想要的东西的时候。我不得不经历某种与之相关的崩溃痛苦，持续了一段时间，直到我向现实投降，承认：你就是得不到。不管你有多想要。你无法让那个人去爱。你。你无法让那个人去爱。你无法改变过去。你无法改变别人的看法。你不能。所以我觉得，我在50多岁时比20多岁时要平静得多，原因在于
was because in my 20s, I was still pretty sure I could get what I wanted if I tried hard enough and worked hard enough or manipulated enough. And I couldn't. Yeah, that's a lesson. That's a lesson that we all learn eventually. And I always think about it as, have you seen the Harry Potter films? Yes, of course. Do I not have eyes? I know.
因为在我20多岁的时候，我还是相当确信，只要我足够努力、拼命工作或足够善于操纵，我就能得到我想要的。但我做不到。是的，这是一个教训。这是我们终究都会学到的教训。我总是这样想，你看过《哈利·波特》电影吗？看过，当然看过。难道我没有眼睛吗？我知道。
Sometimes you've got to ask because there'll be people who are like, what? No. I always think about this scene. It must be in the first movie where they're going to find the philosopher's stone
有时候你得问一下，因为会有人问：什么？没有。我总是想起这个场景。那一定是在第一部电影里，他们去寻找魔法石
and they fall into this pit of vines that like choke them and like just tightening. And every time they like struggle against it and they move, it just gets tighter and tighter and tighter. And it must be like, Kermaini or someone realizes like if I just relax, they'll let me go. They'll let me go and I will just
然后他们掉进了一个藤蔓坑里，藤蔓像要勒死他们一样，而且还在不断收紧。每当他们挣扎反抗、挪动身体时，它就会勒得越来越紧、越来越紧。一定是有个人，比如赫敏或者谁，意识到只要我放松下来，它们就会放开我。它们会放开我，然后我就会
fall straight through. And it is such a hard thing to do because naturally you want a good life and you want to be happy and you want to find love and you want to feel like you are here for a reason. Obviously, like you can't know what that is. So sometimes you do just have to do the opposite of what every single instinct in your body is telling you to do, and that is to just relax. And I think that there is a difference between like survival, like survival instincts and an instinct for living. And I think our living instinct and our life instinct is to relax and is to just have a little bit more fun. But we're confusing that with our survival instincts, which are like, no, run, produce, like hit, scream. Somewhere along the way, like those have gotten crossed. And so now we just feel a lot more
直接坠落下去。要做到这一点是如此困难，因为生而为人，你自然想要美好的生活，想要快乐，想要寻找爱，想要觉得自己来到这里是有原因的。显然，你无法知道那是什么原因。所以有时候你真的必须做相反的事情，去做你身体里每一个本能都叫你去做的事情的对立面，那就是放松。我觉得生存，比如生存本能和生活本能之间是有区别的。我认为我们的生活本能和生命本能是去放松，去享受更多的乐趣。但我们却把它和我们的生存本能搞混了，生存本能就像是：不，快跑，生产，就像打击、尖叫。在不知不觉中，这些本能被混淆了。所以现在我们对一切都感到更加
panicked about everything and we think that small things are going to cost us our life, you know, not having a job that we love, not having people like us, like all these things are going to be a lot more costly than they actually are. That's just how I see it. When I relaxed into that, it felt a lot better. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness. fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
恐慌，我们认为微小的事情会让我们付出生命的代价，你知道的，没有一份我们热爱的工作，没有赢得人们的喜欢，所有这些事情付出的代价都要比实际大得多。这就是我的看法。当我放松下来融入其中时，感觉好多了。2%。这就是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析心理韧性的科学。体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养复原力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
来抛开那些统治着健康产业的很不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨。变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so...
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，不过为了让你们知道我的意思。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆上台面了，所以……
Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
然后你把这句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们对某事进行追求时，我们会太过于投入到追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要，
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
你是一个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，让我们一起来进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话，
on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
就在我的新播客《迎难而上》中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。
This began a years-long court battle, to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾在这个特定的测试中作假过两次，对吗？我只篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Nanchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·南基尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I want to ask you about a bit of a turning point in your career and in your life. and it was the success of E. Pray Love, Julia Roberts starred you in a movie. That's probably something that only three or four people can say. But what happened afterwards? You know, you wrote this book. It's beautiful. It became incredibly popular. How did you manage or deal with the expectations that you maybe experienced for your next book or for after that, the initial fame it may be passed? Oh, what a great question.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我想问你关于你职业生涯和生活中一个转折点的事情，那就是《一、祈祷、爱》的成功，朱莉娅·罗伯茨主演了根据你改编的电影。这大概是只有三四个人能说出口的事情。但之后发生了什么？你知道的，你写了这本书。它很美。它变得非常受欢迎。对于你可能为你下一本书所经历的期待，或者在最初的名气可能消退之后，你是如何管理或应对的？哦，真是个好问题！
So do you know, I mean, I'm talking like I know anything about mathematics, but do you know the principle of absolute value? I'm not, no. I'm not even going to claim to pretend to. I'm going to just throw it out there and explain it, but like imagine that you're looking at a number line and there's a zero in the middle. And then the positive numbers go out in one direction, positive one through 10. And then the negative numbers go out in the other direction, negative one through 10, right? So pick a number three, right? So there's a positive number three and there's a negative number three, right, on that line.
你知道吗，我的意思是，我说得好像我对数学有什么了解一样，但你知道绝对值的原理吗？我不知道，不。我甚至不会假装声称我知道。我只是把它抛出来解释一下，但就像想象你在看一条数轴，中间有一个零。然后正数向一个方向延伸，正一到正十。然后负数向另一个方向延伸，负一到负十，对吧？所以选一个数字三，对吧？所以数轴上有正三，也有负三，对吧？
But they share the same absolute value. So the absolute value means the distance from zero. So there's a zero in our emotional life, which I would describe as just sort of like our stability, constancy, a sense of belonging, a sense of like balance, that's zero, that's point zero, right? And then there are these horrible things that happen on the negative side of the scale. And these wonderful things that happen on the positive side of the scale. Here's where things can get really confusing sometimes. It makes sense that when a horrible thing happens, a divorce or an illness or a death or a terrible breakup or a massive disappointment or a natural disaster, it makes sense that you would be really shook by it. But
但它们共享同一个绝对值。所以绝对值意味着到零的距离。所以在我们的情感生活中有一个零，我把它描述为某种类似于我们的稳定、恒常、归属感、平衡感的东西，这就是零，这就是零点，对吧？然后在量表的负面一侧会发生这些可怕的事情。在量表的正面一侧会发生这些美好的事情。事情有时候会变得非常令人困惑的地方就在这里。当可怕的事情发生时，比如离婚、生病、死亡、糟糕的分手、巨大的失望或自然灾害，你会被它深深震撼，这在情理之中，但是
it doesn't make sense that you would be equally shook when a wonderful thing happens because we're trained to think that the wonderful things are great. But to your nervous system, there's an absolute value of distance from zero. If zero is what I'm used to, what I'm accustomed to, and what I am normal to, and a really big swing in the positive direction, a number 10. So eat pray loves a number 10 on that it's like you just wrote i heard the other day that it's like the second best selling memoir of all time you know it's like yeah so famous like yeah julia roberts you're a millionaire now julia roberts is playing you in a movie you're famous you never have to get a job again you know like yeah all this stuff has happened this is a 10 this is a plus 10
当美好的事情发生时，你也会受到同样程度的震撼，这就说不通了，因为我们受到的训练让我们认为美好的事情都是极好的。但对你的神经系统来说，存在一个到零的绝对值距离。如果零是我习惯的、适应的、习以为常的状态，而朝正方向发生了巨大的摆动，达到了数字10。所以《一、祈祷、爱》在这上面就是个数字10，就像你刚刚写的那样，我前几天听说它就像是有史以来第二畅销的回忆录，你知道的，就像是，是的，如此有名，就像，是的，朱莉娅·罗伯茨，你现在是百万富翁了，朱莉娅·罗伯茨在电影里扮演你，你出名了，你再也不用找工作了，你知道的，就像，所有这些事情都发生了，这是一个10，这是一个正10。
the absolute value is it's 10 steps from zero which has the same impact on my nervous system as if there was an earthquake or a death in the family because it is taken me so far away from what I thought was normal right so it's really important to understand and to expect in life that really good news things can also shake you to the core because it's a long long way away from normal. So what happened was I had to get back to neutral. I had to get back to zero. And the only way that I could do that was that I took a year off, almost a year off from doing anything in public. And I started a garden. I literally had to get back, I had to get on my knees in the ground because I felt so ungrounded. People were telling me all sorts of things about who I
它的绝对值是，它距离零有10步之遥，这对我神经系统产生的影响，就好像发生了地震或家里有人去世一样，因为它把我带得离我自认为正常的状态太远了，对吧？所以非常重要的一点是，要在生活中理解并预料到，真正的好消息和事情同样能震撼你的核心，因为它离正常状态实在太远太远了。所以发生的事情是，我必须回到中立状态。我必须回到零。我唯一能做到这一点的方法就是，我休息了一年，几乎有一年时间没有做任何公开活动。我开始种园子。我真的必须回去，我必须双膝跪在泥土里，因为我感到太不接地气了。人们告诉我各种关于我是谁、我是什么、我的文化重要性是什么的话。所以我不得不回到大地的水平线上。而且我，我园艺了一年。我没有做任何演讲活动。我没有教书。我没有写任何东西。我种了蔬菜。这就是我克服它的方式。在园子里待了一年后，我记得那是冬天，我在扫落叶、堆肥，你知道的，长满老茧的手，还有脏兮兮的衣服。衣服就是这样让我恢复的。然后我听到脑海里响起了下一本书的第一行。就像，就像落叶纷纷落下，一片叶子落入了我的脑海，这就是下一本书的第一行。我当时就想，好吧，我想我准备好再次写作了。所以，所以你必须
was and what I was and what my cultural importance was. And so I just had to get down to the level of the earth. And I, I gardened for a year. I didn't do any speaking events. I didn't teach. I didn't write anything. And I grew vegetables. That's how I got over it. And after a year in the garden, I remember it was like wintertime and I was raking up the leaves and composting things, you know, calloused hands and like just dirty clothes. lows is what did it. And I was, and then I heard in my head the first line to the next book. It was like, it's like the leaves were falling and like a leaf fell into my mind and it was the first line to the next book. And I was like, okay, I think I'm ready to write again. So, so you have
无论你的生活中发生了一件极其正面、无比美妙、巨大崭新而又疯狂的事情，还是发生了一件极其负面、无比糟糕、巨大崭新而又疯狂的事情，你都必须学会脚踏实地。这在当今时代是非常难做到的，特别是伴随着手机上各种事物的不断干扰。但你必须要让自己像贴近大地一样，去海滩，去海里。就像是，你必须变得有点像动物。你知道的，这就像是我必须回归四大元素，回到水、火和土这样的元素中去，因为你需要记住你自身的某种元素，而不是人们对你说的那些疯狂的信息。我记得当20多岁心理学变得非常
to, whether you've had a hugely positive, massively fantastic big new crazy thing happen in your life or a hugely negative, massively horrible, big new crazy thing in your life, you've got to learn how to ground. And it's very hard to do in this day and age, especially with the constant distractions of everything that's on your phone. But you've got to kind of get like low to the earth and like go to the beach and go in the ocean. Like it's, you have to get kind of animal. You know, it's like I've got to get with elemental back down to the waters like fire and water and earth because and you have to remember the sort of element of yourself rather than all the kind of crazy information that people are telling you about you. I remember when the psychology of your 20s was becoming really,
非常受欢迎，并且在网络上疯传，成千上万的人一直在听它的时候。我记得自己从未如此痛苦过，而且一直在哭。我会打电话给我的伴侣汤姆，打电话给我的妈妈和爸爸，然后说：这会被夺走吗？我该如何适应这一切？我清楚地记得那一刻，当时我想：我会没事的。我回到了我长大的地方，也就是昆士兰州的库伦宾。那是人间天堂。我去远足，发现了一棵芒果树，它落下了所有这些……就是这样。完全正确。你这么说太有趣了，因为我真的记得捡起一个芒果，而且我没有刀或叉子。我说，
really popular and it was going viral and it was just thousands of people listening to it all the time. I remember never being more miserable and like crying constantly. I would call my partner Tom and I would call my mom and my dad and just be like, this is going to get taken away from me. How do I adjust to this? And I remember exactly the moment when I was like, I'm going to be okay. And I went back to where I grew up, which is Corrumban in Queensland. It's paradise on earth. And I went on this hike and I found a mango tree that had dropped all these. There you go. Exactly. And it's so funny you were saying that because I literally remember picking up a mango and like I didn't have a knife or fork. And I said,
就像用双手把它撕开，然后吃着它，我当时想，天哪，我将永远拥有这个——如果发生什么可怕的事，我可以来找这棵芒果树，而且……感觉就像你属于大自然，是的，完全正确，你属于这里。玛丽·奥利弗有一首诗，你的，你属于万物的一部分。是的，你知道的，巨大的成功和巨大的失败会让你失去归属感，但是，但是如果你接近自然，你就会记得你属于这里。我喜欢那个故事。太棒了。我仍然记得那个芒果的味道。就像，非常鲜艳。事实上我最近回去了，而那棵芒果树已经不在了。所以我想它只是在我需要的时候出现了。其实你可能不知道的一件事是，
like ripped it open with my hands and like was eating it and I was like oh my god I'll always have this like I can come and find this mango tree if anything terrible happens and um it felt it's like you're of the earth yeah exactly you belong what is Mary Oliver has a poem um your you're part in the belonging of things yes you know great great success and great failure can lose your sense of belonging but the but if you get close to nature you'll remember that you belong here. I love that story. It was amazing. I still remember the taste of that mango. Like, it's very vivid. And I went back actually recently in the mango tree wasn't there. So I guess it just appeared when I needed it. It's actually something you may not know is that
借用一个名人名字在这儿说一下，泰勒·斯威夫特实际上引用了你的一场TED演讲。你，你知道这个吗？我确实听说过。你知道。你知道这个。好的。我觉得非常有趣的是，她引用了你和她的创作过程，并且说，即使人们讨厌我做过的事，即使我失败了，即使我你知道没有取得我想要的成功，创作的驱动力依然要让我继续创作，我必须去创作，我一直也很喜欢那个类比——并不是说，并不是说任何关于他们应该如何生活的理论都需要证据，但你知道，看到她的创作过程不断演变并带给她巨大的成功，我觉得她某种程度上，这意味着，你知道，那是受你启发。所以我觉得当谈到像冒名
to celebrity name drop in here, Taylor Swift actually referred one of your TED talks. Do you, do you know this? I did hear that. You do. You do know this. Okay. And I feel like what was so interesting was she was saying referencing you and her creative process and being like the drive to keep creating even when people hate what I've done even when I've failed even when I've you know not had the success that I wanted I just have to create and I always like that analogy as well like not to not to not that anyone's theory about how they should live their life requires proof but you know seeing that her creative processes continue to evolve and allowed her great success I feel like she's kind of something and that means, you know, that came from you. So I think when it comes to like imposter
顶替综合征，以及因为我们取得了一些成功而觉得自己要失败了，或者觉得自己现在需要为别人做事时。真正的创作者真正明白，再次强调，这不仅仅是一份工作，这不是一个职业，而是一个天职。无论你有零个读者、零个听众、零个观众，还是一百万个，希望你所创作的东西都会是一样的。但在那段旅程中，你是如何应对失败的呢？我知道你提到过你有一本书被取消了。说实话，我甚至不知道这意味着什么。我也不知道，直到它发生在我身上。我写了一本以俄罗斯为背景的书，一本以俄罗斯为背景的小说。当我宣布这件事时，乌克兰人发出了巨大的抗议声，说：
syndrome and feeling like we're going to fail because we've had some success or feeling like we need to now do things for other people. True creatives really understand that, again, it's not just a job, it's not a profession, it's a calling. And whether you have zero readers, zero listeners, zero viewers or a million, hopefully like what you're creating will be the same. But within that journey, how have you dealt with failure? I know you talked about you had a book canceled. I don't even know what that means, to be completely honest. Neither did I until it happened. I wrote a book that was set in Russia and a novel that was set in Russia. And when I announced it, there was an enormous outcry from Ukrainians saying, like,
你知道，当我们在被杀戮和谋杀的时候，你怎么能在这个时候做这种事，把世界的注意力吸引到俄罗斯身上。事实上，当我听到时，我觉得很有道理。所以当我谈到它被取消时，这是一个戏剧化的说法，我喜欢戏剧。我是一个艺术家，但这是一个戏剧化的说法，我的意思是，它确实相当戏剧化，因为它在推特上成了热门话题，而且，他们。是的，当成千上万的人讨厌你的时候。成千上万的人在恨我，告诉我我是为普京工作的，我是个糟糕透顶的人，还去Goodreads网站上，给一本甚至还没出版的书打一星差评。
you know, how could you be doing this right now and pulling the world's attention to Russia when we're being killed and murdered. And actually, it made a lot of sense to me when I heard. So when I say that it was canceled, that's a dramatic way to say, I like drama. I'm an artist, but it's a dramatic way to say, I mean, it was quite dramatic because it was like trending on Twitter and, you know, they. Yeah, when thousands of people hate you. Thousands of people are hating me and telling me that I work for Putin and that I'm awful and going on good reads and putting one-star reviews for a book that. wasn't even published yet.
所以有成千上万条一星评价，说：这是世界上最糟糕的书。我们讨厌这本书。你知道，我的意思是，这是一个，你知道的，戏剧性的时刻。但我让我自己脚踏实地。我有一些我一直在做的练习，以及我多年来学到的精神修行，让我自己保持脚踏实地，这样我才能真正倾听他们在说什么，而不是觉得自己受到了迫害。当我倾听他们所说的话时，我觉得非常合理。我就想：你知道吗？
So there were thousands of one-star reviews saying, like, this is the worst book in the world. We hate this book. You know, I mean, it was, you know, it was a dramatic moment. But I grounded myself. I have practices that I do and spiritual practices that I've learned over the years to ground myself so that I could actually listen to what they were saying rather than feeling that I was being persecuted. And when I listened to what they were saying, it made a lot of sense to me. And I was like, you know what?
我明白了。我要推迟这本书。所以，我们只是决定不出版它。也许有一天它会出版，但事情变得非常简单。一旦你脚踏实地，决定就会变得非常简单。当你处于焦虑或战斗、逃跑或创伤状态时，你是无法调动你的理智思维的。一切都感觉像是着火了。所以这就是为什么学习如何脚踏实地如此重要。但我还要说关于创造力的另一件事。我认为其中一部分原因是，我通过我的神经系统和我的思维了解创造力是如何运作的。我知道我的恐惧中心是我意识思维中最古老的部分。所以在我们进化成这些类人形态之前，在我们拥有其他任何东西之前，我们就已经被赋予了这种令人难以置信的恐惧能力
I get it. I'm going to postpone this book. So it just, we just decided not to publish it. Someday maybe it'll be published, but it became very simple. Once you're grounded, the decisions become very simple. When you're in anxiety or fight, flight, or trauma, you don't have access to your reasonable mind. And everything feels like it's on fire. So that's why it's so important to learn how to ground. But I was going to say one other thing about the creativity. I think part of the thing is that I know how creativity works through my nervous system and through my mind. mind. And I know that my fear center is the oldest part of my conscious mind. So before we had anything else when we were evolving into these humanoid forms, we were given this incredible capacity for fear
和警惕性。我的朋友玛莎称之为“十五只小狗和一条蛇”。或者十五只小狗和一条眼镜蛇，这意味着如果你在一个房间里，里面有十五只小狗和一条眼镜蛇，你的注意力会集中在那条眼镜蛇身上。你知道的，如果不是这样的话，你活不了多久。如果你是那种说“哦，看看那些小狗”的人，你知道的，就像你一样，你的大脑将会是，直到那条眼镜蛇被处理掉，你都不会看到那些小狗，你知道的，这就是生存的现实。这就是你刚才谈到的生存基因。我们都有这个基因。
and alarm. My friend Martha calls it 15 puppies and a snake. So or 15 puppies and a cobra, which means if you're in a room and there's 15 puppies and a cobra, your attention is going to be on the cobra. You know, like if it isn't, you're not going to live long. If you're the kind of person who's like, oh, there's about the puppies, you know, like you, your mind will be, and until that cobra is taken care of, you will not see those puppies, you know, like that's reality of survival. That's the survival gene that you were talking about. We all have that.
我们能在这里，只因为我们的祖先注意到了眼镜蛇，对吧？所以这一点深深地烙印在我的大脑中，我一直在寻找那些会杀死我的东西。我在寻找会出岔子Things。这是内置的。我的创造性思维大约在10万年前才上线，也就是我们共同的创造性思维，基于人类学家和科学家的看法。所以它是新的。另一个已经存在几十亿年了。恐惧中心已经存在几十亿年了。
We're only here because our ancestors paid attention to the cobras, right? So this is deeply embedded in my brain that I'm looking for things all the time that are going to kill me. I'm looking for things that are going to go wrong. It's wired in. My creative mind only came in online about 100,000 years ago, our shared creative mind, but based on what anthropologists and scientists believe. So it's new. The other one is billions of years old. The fear center is billions of years old.
它一直在进化、进化、进化。连蝌蚪都有这个能力，你知道吗？所以每当我创造什么东西时，创造的冲动就会出现并说：我想创造一些新的东西。我的恐惧中心，它的第一要务就是永远不要让我做任何新的事情，因为它为了我的生存必须假设任何新事物都有可能杀死我。所以我的恐惧只希望我做它所习惯的事，做我每天都在做的事，因为我的恐惧觉得：这样做是安全的，我是说，到目前为止我这样做还没有人死过，所以你是……因此，当我向我的大脑灌输“我要做这件新事”时，我的恐惧就会抓狂。它会说：你不能那样做。那会杀了我们的。我们不知道结果。我的恐惧是
It's just been evolving and evolving and evolving. Even tadpoles have it, you know? So whenever I create something, the creative impulse comes and says, I want to make something that's new. my fear center its number one job is to never let me do anything new because it has to assume for my survival that anything new has the potential to kill me so my fear only wants me to do what it does every what i do every day because my fear is like it's safe if you do this i mean no one has died yet from me doing this so you're so when i introduce into my mind i'm going to do this new thing my fear freaks out. And it's like, you cannot do that. That will kill us. We don't know. My fear is not
不允许的。恐惧的工作就是不让我做任何不知道结果的事情。创造力不过就是去做那些你不知道结果的事情。仅此而已。这一点永远不会变。我的意思是，我已经写了十本书了，当我开始写一本书时，我仍然不知道结果会是什么。而且我的恐惧仍然在说：你做不到。我必须阻止它。你会死的。因此，从进化的角度来看，我知道这就是正在发生的事情这一事实，让我更容易去想：哦，这是一个很自然的过程，我的恐惧在说这些话。但我更进化、更近期的那部分大脑，也就是“莉兹4.0版本”其实真的很想尝试做这件事。我需要告诉我的恐惧
allowed. My fear's job is to not let me do anything where it doesn't know what the outcome is. And creativity is nothing but doing things where you don't know what the outcome is. That's all it is. And that never changes. I mean, I've written 10 books now and I still don't know what the outcome is going to be when I start writing a book. And I still have my fear saying, you can't do it. I've got to shut it down. You're going to die. And so the fact that I know that that's what's happening from an evolutionary standpoint makes it easier for me to be like, oh, this is a natural process that my fear is saying these things. But my more evolved, more recent part of my brain, the Liz 4.0 actually would really like to try to do this thing. And I need to tell my fear
这不太可能。还没有人因为读我的书而死。所以有人会死的可能性不大。对，没错。也许会受到严重的纸张割伤，但……对，也就那样。我想我们都没事。也许书架上的书掉下来砸到了某个人的头，但我想这已经是它造成的最大损害了。是的。我想谈谈，既然我们现在在讨论写书的主题，你就在 буквально三天前宣布了《一往直前》（all the way to the river）。我看了你发布的解释视频。差点儿看哭了，并不是想让自己显得太像个狂热粉丝。
that it's unlikely. No one has yet died from my books. So it's unlikely that somebody will die. Yeah, no. Maybe a severe paper cut, but. Yeah, that's about it. I think we're all right. Maybe it fell on someone's head off a bookshelf, but I think that's about the worst damage that it's done. Yeah. I want to talk about now that we're on the theme of writing books, you literally like three days ago announced all the way to the river. And I watched the video that you put out explaining it. Semi cried about it, not to like make myself seem like too much of a fan.
但你能为那些可能不知道这本书创作背景的人解释一下这本书的前提吗？哦，所以这是一本回忆录，它是关于我和我全世界最好的朋友之间的关系的，她的名字叫雷亚·伊莱亚斯（Raya Elias），我们是朋友，天哪，我们做了16年的朋友，15或16年。然后在那段友谊的过程中，我们非常逐渐地爱上了彼此。而我当时嫁给了一个我非常爱的人。她嫁给了一个男人。她是同性恋。
But can you explain the premise of this book for? people who may not know what went into making it. Oh, so this is a memoir, and it's about my relationship with my best friend in the entire world ever, whose name was Raya Elias, and we were friends for, gosh, we're friends for 16 years, 15 or 16 years. And then we very gradually, over the course of that friendship, we fell in love with each other. And I was married to somebody who I loved very much. She was married to a man. She was gay.
我不是，或者诸如此类。我甚至不知道那意味着什么。我甚至不在乎。然后她被诊断出患有晚期癌症。在她被确诊的时候，我知道她还有六个月的生命，我再也无法继续假装这只是我最好的朋友了。我需要向她、也向我现在的离异丈夫表达我的心声，我需要以一种不同的方式去面对这个人。
I wasn't or whatever. I don't even know what that means. I don't even care. And she was then diagnosed with terminal cancer. And at the time of her diagnosis, I was no longer able to, knowing that she had six months to live, I was no longer able to continue just pretending that this was my best friend. and I needed to find my voice to her and to my now ex-husband that I need to go meet with this person in a different way.
她开始把她的死亡称为“河流”，她说：我想让你陪我一直走到河边。我照做了。对于那些不了解这个故事的听众来说，这听起来可能是一个非常浪漫的故事。它确实有非常浪漫的一面。但这也是一段疯狂的旅程。她曾是一个处于康复期的吸毒者，在去世前又重新回到了吸毒状态，这种方式把我们俩脚下的地毯、地板和地面都彻底掀翻了。我陷入了一种与她完全有毒的共同依赖和爱情成瘾的状态。
And she started to call her death the river and she said, I want you to walk with me all the way to the river. And I did. And that may sound to people who are listening to it who don't know the story like a very romantic story. And there were aspects of it that were very romantic. it was also an insane journey. She was a drug addict in recovery who went back into active drug addiction before her death in a way that just ripped the rug, floor, and ground out from under both of us. I fell into a state of totally toxic codependency and love addiction with her.
那是一段地狱般的时光，那是一个地狱般的故事，我花了七年时间才把它写出来，因为我花了这么长时间才从那段经历中疗愈，并在那之后重新找回自我，甚至去理解到底发生了什么。在很多方面，这也是一本关于我们如何在自我中迷失的书。雷亚在那段时间里从她脚踏实地的中心迷失了方向。我在那段时间里也从我脚踏实地的中心迷失了方向。这是一本关于恢复、韧性，以及在经历了如此戏剧性和狂乱的时期后，如何找到通往自己中心的道路的书。当你写这本书的时候，它感觉几乎像是一种宣泄吗？
It was a hell of a time and it was a hell of a story and it's taken me seven years to write it because it took me this long to heal from it and to find my grounding again after that and to even understand what had happened. And in many ways, it's a book about how lost we can get from ourselves. Raya got very lost from her grounded center during that time. I got very lost from my grounded center during that time. And it's a book about recovery and resilience and finding your way back to your center after having been through a time of. such drama and drama. When you were writing it, did it feel almost like cathartic?
就像，你觉得你写它是为了自己多一些，还是为了读者多一些？或者你是否有一种希望，期望人们能从中获得什么？我一直觉得，我的意思是，我写东西是为了理解我的生活。我通过写作来寻求理解。所以这绝对是一种宣泄。话虽如此，这也是一本我其实不想写的书。你知道，有趣的是，那个故事中有一些部分，我当时想：我真希望这一切都没有发生过
Like, do you feel like you wrote it more for yourself than for an audience? Or is there something you're kind of hoping that people are going to get out of it? I always feel, I mean, I write things in order to understand my life. And I write my way into understanding. So it was it was absolutely cathartic. That said, it's the book I didn't want to write. You know, interesting are parts of that story that I was like, I just still want that to not have happened.
那样。就像我仍然希望——我知道我们所有人的生活中都有这样的章节，比如：听吧，我已经和解了，我已经前进了，但别以为我心里不希望事情能有另一种发展，你知道的，或者我得到了不同的结果，或者事情能以另一种方式进行。但这本书在很大程度上也是关于臣服以及向现实臣服的。所以，是的，我为自己写了这本书，但我也认为，这也是我命运的一部分——成为一个经历过非常艰难的事情的人，然后去诠释、翻译这些事情，并把它们公之于众，仿佛在说：“看，这事在你身上发生过吗？如果是的话，以下是我对此的一些想法。”你知道的，这有一些
that way. Like I still want, and I know we all have this in our lives, like chapters of our life where it's like, listen, I've reconciled with it and I've moved on, but like don't think I still don't wish it went a different way, you know, that I had gotten a different outcome or that it had gone a different way. But it is a lot of the books about surrender as well and surrendering into reality. So yeah, I wrote it for myself, but I also, I think that it's part of it. of my destiny to be a person who has things happen to her, they are really hard and then interprets and translates those things and puts them out in public to say like, here, has this ever happened to you? If so, here's some thoughts I have on this. You know, here's some
我从中学到的东西。我认为这也是我命中注定要做的一部分。所以，即使在我写这本书的时候，正在揭露她和我那些绝对可怕的方面——就好像，这正是我不想让别人知道关于我的事情。这完全违背了形象管理，才会去写这样一本书。我的朋友格伦农·多伊尔（Glennon Doyle），作家格伦农·多伊尔在它还是手稿时读了它，并说：这是我读过的最，她是怎么说的来着，最具自我反思能力的。就像这是一堂关于自我反思的大师课，但这也是我觉得我真的很想成为一个极具自我反思能力的人。
things I've learned from this. And I think that's part of what I'm, I think that's part of what I'm meant to do. So even as I was writing the book and exposing these absolutely horrific aspects of her and me, or it's like, this is exactly the stuff I don't want people to know about me. This is exactly like, this is counter to image management is to write a book like this. And my friend Glennon Doyle, the writer Glenn and Doyle read it when it was a manuscript and said, this is the most, what did she say, the most self-accountable thing I've ever read. But like this is a masterclass in self-accountability, but that's also what I feel I really want to be a very self-accountable person.
我不想，因为自我反思的反面就是成为受害者。而且，你知道，那本书对我来说是一次法医般的努力，去试图——对我来说是一次法医般的努力，去试图弄清楚：我在其中扮演了什么角色？你知道的，我是如何——我确实觉得，在我们生活的多个节点上，我们会发现自己在说：
I don't want to, because the opposite of being self-accountable is being a victim. And, you know, that book was a forensic effort for me to try to, is a forensic effort for me, to try to be like, what was my part in this? You know, like how did I, I do feel that it, multiple points in our lives, we will find ourselves saying,
我怎么会落得这个地步？就像，我怎么会落到这步田地的？我怎么会陷入这种有毒的局面？我怎么会陷入这段功能失调的关系？我怎么会陷入这种虐待？我怎么会陷入这种自我否定和自我背叛？怎么会是我？你知道吗？
how did I end up here? Like, how did I end up in this? How did I end up in this toxic thing? How did I end up in this dysfunctional relationship? How did I end up in this abuse? How did I end up in this self-abnegation and self-betrayal? Like, how is that me? You know?
而且很容易就会陷入那种混乱的境地。要再次找到平静和清晰并不是那么容易，但它是可以被找回的。所以我希望这本书能对人们有所帮助。雷亚一直希望我把这个故事讲出来，并说它会帮助到一些人。所以我希望它真的能做到。它什么时候出版？这可能是你应该问的第一个问题。2025年9月9日。
And it's very easy to end up in those sorts of fields of confusion. And not so easy to find serenity and clarity again, but it's findable. So I hope that the book helps people. Raya always wanted me to tell the story and said it'll help some people. And so I'm hoping that it well. And when does it come out? That's probably the first thing I should have asked. September 9th of 2025.
所以它快要来了。就在转角处。对于某人来说，这将会是一份精彩绝伦，但也许非常黑暗和深邃的圣诞礼物。我喜欢。很好的学习。读过这本书的人告诉我。一个朋友昨天刚给我发短信，我给了他一本复印件，他说：我一整天都在读你的书。他说：我一直在狂笑大哭和痛哭流涕之间来回切换。
So it's coming. Right around the corner. It's going to be an amazing, but maybe very dark and deep Christmas present for someone. I like it. Nice learning. I have been told by those who have read it. A friend just texted me yesterday and I gave him a copy and he said, I've been with your book all day. And he's like, I just keep going back and forth from laughing my head off to crying my eyes out.
我说：嗯，感觉挺对的。那正是我当时经历那段时光的感觉。听起来很像生活。事情就是这样发展的。好吧，我现在非常感谢你。我想问你最后一个问题。这是我问所有嘉宾的问题。
And I'm like, well, that feels about right. That's exactly what that time felt like to me. Yeah. Sounds like life. It's going to go. Well, I want to thank you so much now. I want to ask you one final question. This is the question I ask all of my guests.
我想看看你的答案是什么。那么，对于20多岁的人，你最大的建议是什么，或者你希望自己在20多岁时就知道什么？我知道这是一个很大的问题。我很抱歉。好吧，对，我会给出两个，因为它们是分开的。我最大的建议是，再次回到《薄伽梵歌》。这是一部，我的意思是，智慧文本，古老的智慧文本是如此有用，因为它们是数千年人类经验和智慧的精华。
And I want to see what your answer is going to be. So what is your biggest piece of advice for people in their 20s or the thing you wish you knew? when you were in your 20s. I know it is a big one. I'm sorry. Okay, for me, I'll give two because they're separate. My biggest piece of advice is, again, I'm going back to the Bhagavagita. It is such a, I mean, wisdom texts, ancient wisdom texts are so handy because they are the distillation of millennia of human experience and wisdom.
所以我不断地翻阅这本拥有7000年历史的文本并引用其中的内容，绝非偶然。其中的一句话是：宁可不完美地过你自己的生活，也不要完美地模仿别人的生活。这听起来现在可能会成为Instagram上的一条Meme梗图。但这是极其深邃的智慧。宁可不完美地过你自己的生活，也不要完美地模仿别人的生活。我在20多岁时，对很多我见过的为自己树立的生活模板进行了相当不错的模仿，它差点儿把我害死。而对我个人而言，我希望自己当时知道的是：在如此年轻的时候，要避免陷入浪漫的纠缠。尽管这是我比任何事情都更想要、更渴望、更追求的东西，但事实上，它却让我离自己最远，尤其是作为一个女人。它让我处于一种不断回应的状态，尤其是对男人的回应，从我早上醒来直到——我总是和某人住在一起——从我早上醒来直到晚上上床睡觉的每一分钟，我都关注着他，我在回应他，我在围绕他改变自我的形态，我在努力兑现，我试图兑现某种能让他高兴的自己。那是一份兼职工作。我的意思是，也许是一份全职工作，为了从他那里——无论“他”是谁，填空吧——为了从他那里得到爱、认可、接受和喜爱。
So it's not an accident that I keep reaching for this 7,000-year-old text and quoting from it. But one of the lines in there is, it is better to live your own life imperfectly than to live a perfect imitation of somebody else's life. And that sounds like it could be a meme on Instagram right now. But that is deep, deep wisdom. It is better to live your own life imperfectly than to live a perfect imitation of somebody else. else's life. I did a pretty good imitation in my 20s of a lot of lives that I had seen modeled for myself and it almost killed me. And for me personally, it would have, what I wish I had known is to avoid romantic ammashment at such a young age. Even though it was the thing I wanted more than
所以我一直不断地查找这篇历时七千年的文本并引用它，这并非偶然。其中的一句话是：不完美地过你自己的生活，也好过完美地模仿别人的生活。这听起来好像可以是现在Instagram上的一条Meme。但这是深邃无比的智慧。不完美地过你自己的生活，好过完美地模仿别人的生活。在我二十多岁的时候，我很好地模仿了许多我见过的为自己树立的生活榜样，这差点要了我的命。对我个人而言，我希望自己当时知道的是，要避免在如此年轻的时候陷入浪漫的纠缠。尽管这是我比任何事情都更想要的
anything and longed for more than anything and hunted more than anything, it actually took me the farthest away from myself, especially as a woman. It made me be in a constant state of response, especially to men, where from the minute I woke up in the morning until I always lived with somebody, from the minute I woke up in the morning until the minute I went to bed at night, I was aware of him, I was responding to him, I was shape-shifting around him, I was trying to deliver, I was trying to deliver some version of myself that would be pleasing. And it was a part-time job. I mean, maybe a full-time job in order to get from him, whoever the hymn was, fill in the blank hymn, in order to get from him, love, validation, acceptance, and affection,
比任何事情都更渴望、比任何事情都更追逐的东西，它实际上却让我离自己最远，尤其是作为一个女人。它让我处于一种持续的应对状态，尤其是对男人而言，从我早晨醒来的那一刻起——我总是与某人同住——从我早晨醒来的那一刻起，直到我晚上上床睡觉的那一刻起，我都意识到他的存在，我在回应他，我在他周围变形，我试图去交付，我试图交付某种会令人悦目的自我版本。这是一份兼职工作。我的意思是，也许是一份全职工作，为了从他那里——无论是哪个他，填空吧——为了从他那里得到爱、肯定、接纳和关怀，
I turned myself into all sorts of people. And I gave all this time energy that I wish I could have every single minute of that time back. Every single minute of time that I spent trying to get somebody to love me the way I wanted them to love me, I would like every single single minute of that time back. And do you know what I would do at that time? Nothing. I would just sit around looking at things, like reading books, walking around, eating mangoes off the tree, smelling pine cones, jumping in water. I would do nothing of any value if I had every minute of that time left. But the amends that I'm making to myself is that for the next half of my life, I'm keeping it all. I'm keeping all that time for myself and to do nothing with.
我把自己变成过各种各样的人。我付出了所有这些时间和精力，真希望每一分每一秒都能倒流。我花在试图让别人按照我想要的方式去爱我的每一分每一秒，我都希望能拿回来。你知道我会在那个时间做什么吗？什么都不做。我只会坐在那里看着东西，比如看书、散步、从树上摘芒果、闻松果、跳进水里。如果我还剩下了哪怕一分钟的时间，我也不会去做任何有价值的事。但我对自己的补偿是，在我的后半生里，我要把这一切都留着。我要把所有的这些时间留给自己，什么都不用做。
I think that's an amazing philosophy, an amazing philosophy to have. Be center romantic partners in your 20s. Honestly, it's a great tip. So I want to just thank you one more time for coming on the podcast and for sharing all of your wisdom. I honestly feel like I've just done an hour of therapy, free therapy. So thank you for me too. It's a gift. Yeah, it was so beautiful. ways. Yeah, it was so nice. And I hope it's not patronizing for me to say this to you, like sister to women to woman.
我觉得这是一种绝妙的哲学，拥有这种绝妙的哲学。在二十多岁时，以浪漫伴侣为中心。老实说，这是一个很棒的建议。所以我想再次感谢你来到这个播客，分享你所有的智慧。老实说，我感觉自己刚刚做了一个小时的治疗，免费的治疗。所以我也要谢谢你。这是一种礼物。是的，太美妙了。真的。是的，太棒了。我希望这样对你说并不是居高临下的，就像女性对女性一样。
I am so fucking proud of you. Oh, my goodness. Stop. Wow. I am proud of you for creating what you created out of your own imagination and out of your own creativity. And I will tell you something, what you have and what you are, nobody can take away. nobody can take away what you have and what you are you did this and i am so so proud of you for it oh my goodness
我他妈的太为你骄傲了。哦，天哪。住手。哇。我为你用自己的想象力和创造力所创造的一切感到骄傲。我要告诉你一件事，你所拥有的一切和你这个人，是谁也拿不走的。没有人能拿走你所拥有的一切和你这个人，这一切都是你做到的，我为此感到无比无比的骄傲，哦，天哪。
thank you so much that genuinely probably made my year what a what a highlight i appreciate it so much and uh you also have um sorry i just need to gain my words back um you have you're in australia at the moment for some amazing live shows and a workshop in sydney i believe yeah i'll make sure i leave tickets for that, but what cities are you visiting while you're down under? I'm going to Sydney, Melbourne, sorry, Sydney, Malmbs, Brizzy. Oh, she's a local. Oh my goodness. And Hobart, which is the one that I demanded to go to. I'm so sorry, Perth, don't at me. I really, really, really wanted to come to Perth, but they didn't have a venue available that would have been the right size for what we needed, so I wasn't
非常感谢，这真的可以说是让我这一年都过得很值，多么精彩的亮点啊，我太感激了。还有……抱歉，我得整理一下思绪……你目前在澳大利亚，要在悉尼举办一些精彩的现场演出和一个工作坊，如果我没记错的话。是的，我会确保留下那里的门票，但你这次去南半球还参观了哪些城市？我要去悉尼、墨尔本……抱歉，悉尼、墨尔本、布里斯班。哦，她是个当地通。哦，天哪。还有霍巴特，那是我强烈要求去的。非常抱歉，珀斯，别生我的气。我真的、真的、真的很想去珀斯，但他们没有合适大小的场地来满足我们的需求，所以我没有……
will do it. But I have a fascination with Tasmania and I also make it a point whenever I do these tours to try to go to places people don't normally go. And so if you're in Tassie, come because it's going to be great. And Adelaide as well. So, and Adelaide. And if anybody's listening to this in New Zealand, I'm going to Auckland as well. Not to say that I'm lumping you together with Australia, New Zealand. I fully recognize your your absolute beautiful. autonomy and separateness, but while I'm in the neighborhood, I'm also going to Auckland. So please come. And if you've never, I feel like I'm on the tourism board for Tasmania right now, but if you've never been to Tasmania, like I came there 10 years ago and I'm obsessed with it.
我们会去的。但我对塔斯马尼亚有着一种迷恋，而且我每次做巡演时，都会特意去一些人们不常去的地方。所以如果你在塔西（塔斯马尼亚），一定要来，因为那会非常棒。还有阿德莱德。所以，还有阿德莱德。如果有人在纽西兰听到这个，我也会去奥克兰。并不是说我把你们和澳大利亚、纽西兰混为一谈。我完全承认你们绝对美丽的主权和独立性，但既然我在附近，我也会去奥克兰。所以请一定要来。如果你从来没有……我觉得我现在就像是塔斯马尼亚旅游局的人，但如果你从来没有去过塔斯马尼亚，就像我十年前去过的那样，我对它简直着迷了。
And I'm going back to the Museum of Sex and Death because it's the most incredible place like I've ever been to. I feel like it's the most wild thing I've ever seen a human create is that entire, like the whole city is beautiful. So come. There's still tickets left there. There's still tickets left in Adelaide. I think there's a few tickets left in Brissy. But come and join us. It's going to be more like this. Yeah, which we love. Tidbit. I was literally in Hobart like three days ago because my best friend is there. Yeah. And I got her a ticket to your show. So hopefully she loves it. It's honestly magical. I saw a white. I saw an albinos stag. I picked like fresh blackberries off of the trees. Like just like. Like, just like. only a kilometer out of the city. It's beautiful. Go to preachers, the bar. It's the best.
我要再去一次性与死博物馆，因为那是我去过的最不可思议的地方。我觉得我见过的最疯狂的人类创造物就是整个那个地方，就像整座城市都很美一样。所以来吧。那里还有票。阿德莱德也还有票。我想布里斯班还剩几张票。快来加入我们吧。这将会更像这样。是的，我们很喜欢。顺便说一句，我 literalmente（ literalmente 在西班牙语里是“字面上/真的”，这里应该是口语顺便说一句）三天前还在霍巴特，因为我最好的朋友在那儿。是的。我还给她买了一张你的演出票。所以希望她会喜欢。这真的太神奇了。我看到了一只白色的。我看到了一只白化雄鹿。我还从树上摘了新鲜的黑莓。就像……就像……就在离城市一公里远的地方。太美了。去普雷奇斯酒吧（Preachers）吧，那是最好的。
Okay. And thank you, sweetheart, for sharing me with your audience. And everybody out there, listen, it's all going to be all right. Just relax just relax as you're being tormented and tossed about in wild seas. I feel like that summarizes it. Just surrender. So surrender was the theme of this episode. And I want to thank everyone for listening.
好的。谢谢你，亲爱的，把我和你的听众分享。还有外面的各位，听着，一切都会好起来的。在狂风巨浪中被折磨和抛来抛去时，放松点，放松点。我觉得这总结了一切。只要臣服。所以“臣服”就是这一集的主题。我要感谢大家的收听。
If you've made it this far, what's our emoji for the day? Let's choose the earth. You've made it to this part of the show. Drop an earth emoji in the comments so that we can talk and chat about your thoughts, feelings. Maybe your questions, your qualms about this episode. Make sure that you're following along on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And until next time, stay safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself.
如果你坚持听到了这里，我们今天的表情符号是什么？让我们选择地球。你已经听到了节目的这一部分。在评论区留下一个地球表情符号，这样我们就可以讨论和聊聊你的想法、感受。也许还有你关于这一集的疑问、顾虑。确保关注我们的 Instagram：@That Psychology Podcast。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。
And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, it was good, y'all. You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，过得怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全去坦诚交流的对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样做。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple 苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难学到的教训》。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吧？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大群互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰日尼（Michael Ranjini）。我的天呐，我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura, Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple 苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
我剖析了我们这个奇怪现代世界中坚韧不拔的科学、健身和培养抗挫力的秘诀。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。名字叫 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。收听《好姐妹》。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple 苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。